en la comité de la cámara de
representantes que Investiga el ataque
del 6 de enero del 2021 al Capitolio por
parte de simpatizantes de Donald Trump
permitió una citación este viernes para
que Donald Trump entregue documentos
claves en la investigación antes del 4
de noviembre y testifique bajo juramento
el 14 de noviembre o en una fecha
cercana concretamente el comité le está
pidiendo el expresidente que entrega
información suficiente sobre cada
teléfono u otro dispositivo de
comunicación que usó desde el 3 de
noviembre del 2020 hasta el 20 de enero
del 2021 también solicitó
específicamente comunicaciones
realizadas en Sigma una aplicación de
mensajería telefónica encriptada en
cualquier dispositivo personal o
comunicación realizada por cualquier
otro medio Además le pidió
comunicaciones que el expresidente tuvo
con Roger Stone agente del servicio
secreto Anthony ornato los abogados
y más de una docena de miembros de
grupos extremistas la situación viene
después de que el comité votara por
unanimidad del 13 de octubre que en una
audiencia final que proporcionó nuevas
pruebas y testimonios para reforzar el
argumento del panel bipartidista de que
la violencia del 6 de enero fue
resultado directo y predecible de las
decisiones del ex presidente